jetzt dass es endlich soweit die spd hat
eine neue spitze und norbert walter
borjans und saskia esken bin ich sehr
zufrieden mit der bisherigen arbeit der
bundesregierung
das hilft die große frage auf ist die
große koalition jetzt am ende eigentlich
hatten in dieser woche mit einem ganz
anderen titel geplant weil uns war
irgendwie klar olaf scholz das rennen um
die parteispitze machen mit ihm im
chefsessel der spd hätte merkel einfach
weiter regieren können
er hat die groko nie in frage gestellt
gilt als ihr treuer kollege doch dann
kam alles anders
jetzt also saskia esken norbert walter
borjans die beiden sie mit einer klaren
ansage in den wahlkampf getreten
mit uns wird es kein weiter so in der
großen koalition geben aber schon fallen
die türen ein bisschen milder aus in der
talkshow von anne will stellten die
beiden direkt klar denn der abstimmung
unterlegene bundesfinanzminister soll im
amt bleiben er sei wichtig für die
partei und mache eine gute arbeit was
also will die spd genau und wie lange
die union das noch mit nehmen sie sich
ein paar minuten zeit zum lesen sie die
woche